now to california where wildfires are
exploding in size
forcing thousands of people from their
homes take a look at this video showing
destruction from the massive
dixie fire the flames wiped out the
center of the historic town of
greenville yesterday
the fire now the eighth largest in
california history
is one of more than a dozen large
wildfires burning there
jonathan bigliotti is in colfax at the
fast growing river fire jonathan good
and morning morning to you we're
standing in a neighborhood that appears
to be completely destroyed home
after home looks like this one reduced
to rubble
the river fire started yesterday
afternoon it quickly exploded to 1400
acres
north of where we are is the dixie fire
it's about 200 times the size of this
one
and growing by the hour
the flames of the dixie fire gutted the
entire town of greenville california
homes stores and gas stations burned to
the ground
the fire is on the move exploding to
about 20 thousand acres in a single day
it's now covering 278 thousand acres and
35 percent contained
it's ok once you get past that
firefighters struggle to drive through
smoke
as strong winds and the dry vegetation
and brush
are fueling the fire residents are
packing up most difficult part i guess
is just not knowing
what's happening and where it's at it's
just you know it just explodes so fast
you just don't have time to
react with anything more than three
hours away
people in placer and nevada counties are
leaving their homes because of the river
fire
some with just the clothes on their
backs shaking like a leaf but
it's ok i've got my family together and
that's what's important
flames created fireballs like this one
and damaged as many as 45 buildings
firefighters worked to create brake
lines with bulldozers
to prevent more damage right up the
canyon
in the trees and all the brush
i'm just concerned that tomorrow i might
not have one
and fire crews are going to have a busy
day ahead of them red flag warnings
remain in effect through the evening
wind gusts could reach up to 35 miles
per hour
turning hot spots like this into major
flames
dana all right jonathan thank you